[Music]
Senate committee now hear from Jacob
Lawson climate is s chief coordinator
may the record reflect that he was
nearly one hour late yeah sorry about
that and literally had to fly in from
outer space thanks to the system of
satellites natural disasters have become
a thing of the past we can control our
weather mr. president one of our
thermosphere eight satellites
malfunctioned over Afghanistan so your
proposal is what we shut down all
satellites I don't need to remind all of
you how many people died from
catastrophic climate condition make sure
there's no further reason US are you
going back up space coming back I
promise
have a safe trip sir just don't touch
anything
this is mr. Kay Clausen z:j closer you
look much older than I would have
thought
I mean look good I couldn't fire my axis
has been blocked so sadly has a bad cop
that happens this wasn't a malfunction
it was intentional
there's potential for catastrophic
weather events on a global scale a Geo
storm we have to shut the system down
[Music]
the only one who has the kill coats is
the president I mean your health you're
soliciting a Secret Service agent
seriously we're kidnapping the president
in a self-driving cat
[Music]
Jake if you can't stop it no
[Music]
you're committing treason oh yeah I
can't have the president I just own the
state secrets yeah anything I'm
forgetting honey honey
are you
[Music]
[Music]